imagine all the extra time you'd have if
you didn't waste eight hours a day
sleeping
more time for work family and
fun uh-oh looks like you're already
hallucinating
what would be the short-term effects of
not sleeping
how would it impact your daily life
and what would happen to you after your
insomnia challenge was over
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you didn't sleep for a week
you spend about one third of your life
sleeping
while you catch some z's your body
conserves energy stores new information
and even gets rid of toxic waste
you need different amounts of sleep
during your life
in your first year you needed up to 17
hours of sleep each day
and before age 12 you need up to 13
hours
as an adult seven to nine hours each
night should do the trick
cut sleep out of your life
and you could be on the road to extreme
fatigue paranoid delusions and
even death
if you plan to go an entire week without
sleep
you'd probably want to start things off
on the right note
how about an adequate eight hours of
shut eye the night before
well
restful sleep is more than lying down
with your eyes closed
there are several stages
at first everything slows down
that includes your brain waves and your
heart rate
your temperature lowers
eventually your whole body relaxes
during deep sleep your body replenishes
its energy and repairs its cells
and in the last stage rapid eye movement
or rem sleep your brain activity
increases again
this is when you dream and process
information
your first day without sleep would be
pretty typical
you'd be as energetic and as alert as
usual
after a full day of work and activity
you'd start to feel fatigued
but around bedtime you'd have to force
yourself to stay awake
[Music]
after 24 hours you'd already feel the
effects of skipping a night of sleep
you'd have trouble paying attention your
hand-eye coordination would be a little
clumsy
and your ability to make decisions would
be slightly impaired too
you should not get behind the wheel of a
car
being awake for a full day
would be like having the blood alcohol
concentration of 0.1
that's well over the legal limit
as the day wears on your appetite mood
and stress levels would be significantly
affected too
after 36 hours awake hormones like
cortisol insulin or human growth hormone
would be out of balance
you could also make riskier decisions
be inflexible in your reasoning and have
impaired speech
hopefully your job isn't one where the
wrong word choice or intonation could
have outsized consequences for the world
staying awake through the second night
in a row would be a real struggle
at this point you could even experience
so-called micro sleeps
when your brain would enter involuntary
sleep-like states
waking up from these would be
disorienting and confusing
seeing the dawn again you wouldn't feel
so great
after
hours without sleep your immune system
would be disrupted
your body would be less prepared for
threats to your health like bacteria and
viruses
on day three your body's overwhelming
urge to sleep would impact your ability
to think
you wouldn't be able to perform basic
tasks or pay attention
hey
wake up you'd become irritable
anxious and even depressed
you'd have a hard time recognizing the
differences between angry and happy
facial expressions
after 72 hours your perception would be
significantly altered and you'd still
have half the week to go
you could experience hallucinations
ah
seeing things that aren't there
or have illusions
misinterpreting things that are there
despite all these dangers somehow you'd
make it through the 168th hour that's
one full week
hopefully you'd still have your job your
family and your sanity
at long last you could finally sleep
again
if you were able to
when tyler shields an american
photographer experimented with staying
awake for 40 days
it took him eight hours to finally get
to sleep
okay let's not mince words
sleeping isn't for the week
it's for the living
if you're worried about an exam or a
deadline
trying to go without sleep even for one
night
could set you on a dangerous path
but what if your body didn't need to
sleep at all
well
that sounds like a story for another
what if